officers
are investigating an officer-involved
shooting
in the
area block 1800 block of fawn hedge
avenue
this morning at just before 1 30
officers were called to the area in
reference to a domestic violence
situation
during the incident a subject was
believed to be armed
fled
made contact with an officer during that
incident
the subject was fired upon he did
sustain a gunshot wound and was
transported to umc hospital
so as for that the
person is alive as for the officer he is
uninjured the name of the officer will
come out in 72 hours
through press release
though as for that the surrounding
neighborhood is currently closed off we
do ask the public that they do avoid the
area for the time being officers will be
here for the next few hours conducting
their investigation as well as
detectives
so with that are there any follow-up
questions what led the officer to
believe that the suspect was armed to
begin with so this was due to
people calling in and saying that the
subject was armed officer cuevas you
said that um the
suspect had made contact with the
officer did he shoot at him what what
did you mean by that so as for that it's
still in the preliminary stages of the
investigation detectives are working out
the fine details more details will come
out later
this domestic violence call was it
something that happened in the area and
then he left the house or what did that
exactly look like correct as for that it
did occur inside a residence and then
when the subject fled
he went to still same similar area
not too far from the residence and
that's where the ois did occur do we
know the status of the other person
involved in the dispute
as for
the domestic violence the wife or woman
that was involved uh as for that it's
it's still preliminary investigation
so at this time it's believed that it's
only between two subjects the suspect
and
the victim
the victim is said to be okay at this
time did the victim call the police
that i don't have that information
have you had any contact with this
household or couple before a lot of
times domestic violence is something
that occurs over and over again
uh as for that i don't have the
information at this time but i can
definitely circle back and get to you
was there a weapon recovered
uh i don't have that information
can you clarify the relationship between
the suspect and the victim i cannot at
this time do they both live in the house
together
uh that i cannot confirm at this time
anything else want to have
no
thank you thank you so much
thank you